ever since Edwin Hubble discovered that
the universe is expanding there has been
a great debate about the speed of the
suspension also called the Hubble
constant in 2000 scientists thought they
had reached consensus with the Hubble
constant at about 72 but since then two
methods of calculating the expansion
rate have gotten farther and farther
apart and some scientists think it's too
big of a difference to just be a
statistical clue to calculate the Hubble
constant we need both a velocity and a
difference velocities are easy it
requires measuring the redshift of a
galaxy as it receives but distances are
much harder we need standard candles
objects that shine with an intrinsic
brightness that way it's observed
brightness could be converted to a
distance the first method used to
calculate the Hubble constant originated
with Hubble himself he started by
measuring distances to nearby objects
and working his way out hence the name
the cosmic distance letter the first
rung is within our Milky Way here we
measure the distances to seppius
pulsating stars that have an intrinsic
brightness then we look to nearby
galaxies that contain both sethius and
another type of standard candle type 1a
supernova these exploding white dwarf
stars also have an intrinsic brightness
after calibrating these supernovae
astronomers can then move out to a third
rung - even more distant galaxies that
only contains supernovae linking all
these measurements a recent study has
pinned the Hubble constant at 73
instead of starting within our galaxy
and looking out the second method looks
back in time to almost the beginning of
the universe here we find the Cosmic
Microwave Background the radiation left
over from the Big Bang the CMB subtle
variations in temperature described
changes in the density of the universe
right after the Big Bang instead of
standard candles physicists use the size
of the tiny fluctuations as standard
yard surface with these yardstick
they can calculate what the hubble
constant would be today recent estimates
are at about 68 significantly lower than
the cosmic distance ladder approach both
camps hope to resolve this debate in the
coming years with the help of new
telescopes and instruments but if the
discrepancy in the Hubble constant
remains it could mean that our
understanding of the expansion of the
universe is missing and agrees that
something happens between the Big Bang
and President
maybe there's a neutrino out there we
haven't discovered maybe the mysterious
force dark energy which makes up a
significant portion of our universe can
change in strength or maybe subtle flaws
in one or both approaches to the Hubble
constant are giving us the wrong answer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you